in america
far-right extremism is now considered a
greater domestic
threat than islamist terrorism he
started shooting like everyone
and across the world a growing number of
lone actors
with no traditional links to terrorist
organizations
are prepared to attack and kill for
their beliefs
i started to build this hateful mindset
i'm just
going out there and killing people
what's causing this spread of extremist
ideology
like a virus right-wing extremism has
mutated in unpredictable ways
we have seen some of the extremist
channels explode in terms of their
membership
and what can be done to stop hateful
words from becoming
deadly actions
when the christchurch attacker walked
into the al noor mosque
in march 2019 he wasn't just carrying
firearms
he was also equipped with far-right
extremism's latest weapon
a helmet cam connected to a facebook
live stream
[Music]
nearly 200 watched his murderous attack
live
with many quickly replicating and
sharing the footage
within hours it had gone viral
police are investigating reports that an
attacker live streamed their actions
the terrorists of christchurch really
had a very strategic campaign in mind
unfortunately his methods were really
effective because
it was recycled in these online farad
communities as propaganda materials to
recruit from young audiences from gaming
audiences
because they made video game versions of
it they made glorifying memes and
visuals
from his materials that he had posted
online and
that was then used to inspire future
attacks
the christchurch attack revealed just
how much the far-right has evolved
since the days of the ku klux klan
rather than having formal ties to a
specific localized group or party
the christchurch attacker was part of a
loose global community of online
extremists
and therefore considered a lone actor
one of the most difficult types of
terrorists for security services to
detect
when you have a kid who knows how to use
a vpn to disguise
their internet connection sitting in
front of their computer
these individuals self-radicalized get
themselves some kind of a weapon
and it's just really hard to trace you
know it's one actor with no obvious
connection to any particular group
you're monitoring
[Music]
a report by the new zealand royal
commission found the christchurch
attacker was radicalized by content on
youtube
and other online platforms
but it's not just social media channels
that provide a platform for far-right
extremists
they've also used online gaming forums
to promote transnational
racial ideas like the great replacement
a conspiracy theory that states that
whites are being supplanted by non-white
populations
many right-wing extremists feel that
they're fighting what is essentially a
defensive war in which they are the
victims
and they are fighting against
people who would replace them with
a grand multicultural race or some other
dominant race
recent study from cyber security for
democracy
found that far-right accounts are more
successful than other kinds of accounts
at getting likes
shares and other forms of user
engagement
what attracts us most or what captivates
our attention
has still not changed from a few hundred
years ago when we like to watch uh
bloody fights between gladiators or
witches being hung we like radical and
bloody content we like incredible
content we like conspiracy theories
and that means that radical groups have
a much easier time to spread their
messages online than moderate groups
social media algorithms have so far
worked in the favor of far-right
extremists
keen to share their ideology
[Music]
since the early days of the internet
far-right extremists have been
responsible for around 700 terrorist
attacks worldwide
and from 2015 to 2019 the number of
far-right attacks
has grown to over 60 every year
and the number of younger extremists has
been growing
in britain alone numbers of 15-20 year
olds referred to the government's
counter-terrorism programme
prevent over suspected far-right
involvement
have soared to well over 400 every year
since 2017. the advent of digital
culture has given
right-wing extremists a really
unparalleled tool for recruitment
they can now reach directly into the
homes of
really young kids and hook them with
a form of propaganda that is very much
influenced by
broader digital culture some groups have
even been led by teenagers
such as the thirteen-year-old estonian
boy nicknamed commander
who was one of the heads of the neo-nazi
foyer krieg division
and in february this year a british 16
year old boy
was sentenced for terrorism offences
having led an online
neo-nazi group during the pandemic
online far-right internet activity
boomed
between march and april of 2020
membership of sites that discuss
the boogaloo a term used by extremists
to describe an impending civil war
doubled to over 72
000 as conspiracy theories spread
the un warned that right-wing extremists
were using covert 19 related
disinformation to radicalize fundraise
and inspire attacks we have seen some of
the
extremist channels explode in terms of
their membership because people
have been more fearful also more lonely
often sitting at home
and spending their late evenings or
weekends in some of the communities
where extremist groups recruit from
[Music]
before the pandemic those on the fringes
of the mainstream right
were fairly distinct from conspiracy
theorists and members of the far right
but worryingly disaffection with
governments over their handling of
covert 19
has opened up some common ground
the pandemic is thrown together both
online
and in these anti-lockdown protests
groups that would
maybe not have previously been exposed
to one another
and the far right extremists are able to
use
both the conspiracy theories and the
disaffection
of these more sort of
politically mainstream individuals as a
recruitment tool again
collapsing the difference between what
they believe and what the other groups
believe
tech companies have so far been slow to
acknowledge their role
in providing a platform for far-right
extremists
within the past few months facebook
twitter and others
have started to restrict some groups but
de-platforming is not without its
problems
you might decrease the reach that
extremists have but that also means that
they move to the smaller fringe
platforms where they can share even more
radical and violent content because
they're not being monitored there
one of the biggest challenges for the
tech firms and also the security forces
is
the pace at which far-right extremists
move across the internet
they're really good at circumventing new
policies that platforms introduce
they still manage to build up their own
safe havens
another tech solution being developed is
automatic software
that directs those searching for
extremist content towards alternative
narratives
while these tools could derail some
paths to radicalization
state-level solutions coordinated
between governments
may be needed to bring about effective
change
[Music]
if there was something like a global
approach to really
tackling farad extremism that would be
really helpful because online
borders don't really matter and if one
government imposes
a restriction on far-right extremist
content and another one doesn't that
means that extremists still
can go online and and basically spread
their ideologies in whatever country
they want
america has lagged behind other nations
in combating the threat of far-right
extremism
unlike germany or britain america has no
legal mechanism
to forbid domestic far-right extremist
groups
and individuals cannot be prosecuted for
being part of them
despite these challenges there are laws
that could be used to target potential
domestic terrorists
yet some believe there's been a lack of
political will to enforce them
[Applause]
it's not always the case that a
particular government in power will have
preventing far-right extremism as the
top of their list of priorities
freedom of speech laws in america mean
that unlike in many other countries
even hate speech is protected and this
leniency
has had global repercussions
the us really matters here because a lot
of
tech firms that host far-right extremist
content are based in the us
so they determine basically what is
being taken offline globally
left to self-regulate many tech
companies have resisted fully enforcing
even their own rules to restrict
extremist content
but there are some promising signs
facebook's removal of hate speech has
risen eight-fold
in just the past two years and it
recently announced it was stopping
algorithms recommending political groups
to users
[Music]
however even in the best-case scenario
the internet will continue
to be an effective tool in radicalizing
and recruiting more people worldwide
[Music]
every attack feeds the beast this
culture that they have of mythologizing
those who perpetrated these atrocities
merely inspires more
and unless something is done to
stem the flow of people disaffected
and susceptible to recruitment more will
be radicalized and we'll see more
attacks
when president biden took office in
january
he claimed that tackling far-right
extremism was a priority
a rise of white supremacy domestic
terrorism
that we must confront and we will defeat
but details so far have been lacking in
march a joint intelligence paper
said that racially motivated extremism
was
the biggest threat facing america but
how the administration intends to tackle
the problem remains
unclear at this point experts agree
especially in light of hardships brought
about by the pandemic
there's no time to lose i do think it's
hugely important that policymakers now
look at the population segments that are
the hardest hit by the crisis in order
to prevent them from
being lured into extremist networks so
that we can provide them with
alternative solutions
before the extremists do
i'm andrew knox a news editor for the
economist to read more of our coverage
click the link
thanks very much for watching